right so here's your medication dr sohal
goyal is suddenly slammed with demand
for the coven 19 antiviral treatment pax
levitt we will not be able to
accommodate everyone that is referred to
us the federal government has
distributed 150 000 courses of pax
levitt nationally ontario will now allow
some pharmacies to give out the
medication but most provinces still work
from a centralized system meaning the
drug is only accessible through
hospitals and assessment centers my
message to all canadians who may be in
high risk such as the immunocompromised
figure out in your community
right now
how you can get access to that
medication should you need it timing is
key pax paxlevit is only effective five
days after the onset of symptoms in
alberta where eligibility was recently
expanded experts are concerned not
everyone can figure out the system on
their own people who are high risk
have been able to book a pcr test to
document infection and then if you test
positive on a pcr test instructions on
how to access available therapies has
been provided with that result but i
think that's been below the radar for a
lot of people leading to worries
thousands of boxes are going unused of
16 000 courses available in that
province just 670 about 4 percent have
been prescribed health canada says it
plans to work with jurisdictions to
mobilize the drug but that takes time we
really have to make sure that the most
vulnerable people in our society
understand that if they have the
slightest symptom we're better off
assuming that this might be coveted an
assumption that could lead to a quick
diagnosis and a prescription for this
potentially life-saving treatment jamie
morocco global news toronto